bonjour à tous
ils ont va à nouveau
spinoza que j'ai déjà abordé plusieurs
fois sur cette chaîne mme espinosa dont
on n'a jamais réellement fait le tour de
la pensée une pensée extrêmement dense
extrêmement profonde est extrêmement
subtile et aujourd'hui on va revenir sur
l'un des concepts absolument clé de
l'oeuvre spinosi yen à savoir le
déterminisme le déterminisme de spinoza
est très souvent mal compris parce qu'on
a tendance à vouloir en faire la preuve
que la liberté n'existe pas et ce
faisant on se méprend sur la définition
spin aux hyènes de la liberté on lui
fait dire ce qu'il ne dit pas car en
réalité pour spinoza remet une forme de
liberté est possible à cette nuance près
que la liberté chez spinoza ne s'oppose
pas au déterminisme et au contraire elle
l'inclût chez spinoza
la liberté n'est pas incompatible avec
ce qu'il appelle la nécessité la
nécessité désignant le fait que tout ce
qui est et tout ce qui arrive doit être
et doit arriver en vertu d'une chaîne de
causalité absolument implacable c'est ça
qu'on appelle le nécessitent harris mme
qui est une des modalités du
déterminisme l'idée que les évènements
s'enchaînent de manière nécessaire de
manière inévitable selon la loi des
causes et des effets et donc on va voir
dans l'audio d'aujourd'hui en quoi cette
idée de nécessité ne s'oppose pas à la
liberté
en quoi la liberté est possible dans un
système de la nécessité ce qui va nous
permettre de comprendre en bout de
chaîne
en quoi le déterminisme n'est pas le
fatalisme
en quoi le déterminisme ne signifie pas
que tout est déjà écrit
alors pour le comprendre on va commencer
par rappeler ce que signifie le concept
de déterminisme donc le déterminisme
c'est la conception selon laquelle de ce
qui arrive arrive en vertu du principe
de causalité
autrement dit que tout ce qui est est le
résultat d'un enchaînement de causes et
d'effets alors ce qui est très pratique
avec ce concept de déterminisme c'est
qu'il est facile à illustrer est
l'exemple le plus simple à concevoir
c'est celui de la rangée de domino si
vous disposez un certain nombre de
dominos les uns derrière les autres et
que vous poussez le premier domino de
telle sorte qu'il tombe sur le deuxième
est bien là vous allez expérimenté sous
vos yeux la loi de la causalité
l'enchaînement des causes et des effets
à savoir que chaque domino va être la
cause de la chute du suivant donc chaque
domino va subir la poussée du précédent
ça ça correspond à l'effet et en
subissant cette poussée le domino va
entraîner la chute du suivant il devient
la cause de la chute du domino qui lui
succède et jusqu'où cet enchaînement des
causes et des effets va-t-il se
poursuivre bien jusqu'au dernier domino
la chute du dernier domino étant les
faits ultime la conséquence dernière de
la chute de tous les dominos précédent
eh bien le déterminisme c'est tout
simplement ça c'est l'idée que chaque
domino a entraîné la chute du suivant
dans un enchaînement de causalité ou
tous les éléments sont liés les uns aux
autres tous les dominos sont comme lé
maillon d'une longue chaîne des maillons
interdépendants inter reliés ou le sort
de chacun dépend en effet dépendre le
sort des autres
donc c'est vraiment ça l'idée du
déterminisme l'idée d'une suite l'idée
d'une chaîne et si l'exemple fonctionne
avec des objets inertes tels que les
dominos et vous allez voir que ça
fonctionne aussi avec les comportements
humains
autrement dit le déterminisme ne
s'applique pas seulement aux corps
physique inanimé et c'est ça d'ailleurs
qui rend la thèse de spinoza
particulièrement intéressante
alors prenons un exemple qui fait
intervenir des paramètres humains
si vous écoutez cet audio c'est
peut-être parce que vous avez reçu une
notification et pourquoi est ce que vous
avez reçu une notification et bien parce
que vous avez activé la cloche et ce qui
fait que vous avez activé la cloche
c'est le fait que vous avez souhaité
être averti de la sortie de mes nouveaux
audio et qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous
avez souhaité en être avertis et c'est
peut-être le fait que vous aimez écouter
des audio de philosophie que ce vous
avez déjà écouter vous ont donné envie
de vous abonner pour pouvoir écouter les
suivants et donc si on remonte la chaîne
de causalité la suite logique des causes
et des effets qui vous ont conduit là
maintenant à écouter cet audio bien vous
allez voir qu'il s'agit d'une suite
d'événements liés les uns aux autres à
l'origine de cet enchaînement de causes
et d'effets il y as peut-être le fait
que vous avez tapé spinoza dans votre
barre de recherche ou bien cet audio
sera-t-il apparu dans votre fils de
recommandation mais dans les deux cas ça
ne fait que reporter la question ça ne
fait que repousser d'un cran la chaîne
de causalité parce qu'il y à bien une
raison pour laquelle vous avez tapé
spinoza dans votre barre de recherche
de même qu'il y à bien une raison pour
laquelle mon audio apparaît dans votre
fille de recommandation
l'idée du déterminisme c'est que tout ce
qui arrive tout événement n'est jamais
le fruit du néant n'est jamais le fruit
d'une apparition spontanée autrement dit
c'est l'idée que rien n'arrive sans
cause et que tout ce qui est tout ce qui
arrive est le résultat d'un enchaînement
de causes et d'effets
que ce soit pour des phénomènes purement
physiques comme la chute des dominos ou
pour des phénomènes psychologiques ou
comportementaux dans tous les cas il y a
toujours une chaîne causale
dans tous les cas il y a toujours un
processus explicatif
alors évidemment le concept de
déterminisme ne signifie pas qu'on
connaisse toujours les causes de ce qui
arrive
l'idée du déterminisme n'est pas de dire
qu'on peut connaître toutes les causes
de ce qui arrive
l'idée de dire qu'il n'ya pas d'effets
sans cause parce qu'un effet sans cause
c'est absurde
c'est irrationnel donc même si on ne
connaît pas les causes qui sont à
l'origine d'un événement on sais malgré
tout que ces causes existent elles
peuvent nous échapper
elles peuvent être invisible mais le
fait est que cette chaîne de causalité
existe
c'est très important le signal est non
seulement tout obéit à la loi du
déterminisme
mais ce déterminisme prend la forme chez
spinoza d'une nécessité
et la nécessité contrairement à ce que
les usages courants de ce terme pourrait
laisser entendre ce n'est pas le devoir
ce n'est pas l'obligation au sens
normative du terme quand on dit qu'on
est obligés de faire quelque chose ça
relève d'une norme humaine ça relève
d'une règle ça relève d'un décret alors
que la nécessité au sens philosophique
ça désigne ce qui ne peut pas être
autrement
ce qui ne peut pas arriver d'une autre
manière
par exemple il est nécessaire que si
vous sortez sous la pluie sans votre
parapluie à vous allez être mouillé
c'est nécessaire c'est à dire que vous
ne pourrez pas l'éviter
c'est inéluctable et donc si on s'en
tient à cette idée cette idée selon
laquelle tous les événements arrivent de
manière déterminée est nécessaire et ça
devient très difficile de croire dans
concept de liberté
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on fait une
action que l'on croit libre que l'on
croît être le fruit de notre volonté le
fruit d'une décision bien en réalité on
s'aperçoit que ce n'est que le terme
ultime d'un enchaînement de causes et
d'effets
en écoutant cet audio vous avez
peut-être cru accomplir un acte libre
vous avez peut-être cru faire un choix
un choix qui n'est déterminé par rien
d'autre que par votre volonté mais en
réalité selon spinoza
vous n'avez pas agi en être libre vous
n'avez pas agi par un décret de votre
volonté votre action n'était rien
d'autre que le bout de la chaîne de
causalité pour spinoza remet le monde
est gouverné par la loi du déterminisme
les gouvernés par la loi de la nécessité
à savoir que tout ce qui existe et
l'effet d'une série de causes antérieur
et que chaque nouvel effet devient
lui-même la cause d'un effet suivant
alors cette vision des choses contient
deux implication deux applications sur
lesquelles il me paraît utile de
s'arrêter
la première implication et vous la
comprendrait aisément c'est que le monde
est temporel
pourquoi temporel mais parce que pour
qu'il y ait enchaînement de causes et
d'effets il faut bien supposer une
temporalité qui va héberger qui va être
le lieu de déploiement de cette
causalité la causalité implique la
succession dans le temps
elle implique l'antériorité et la
postériorité elle implique un avant et
un après et si le temps n'existait pas
bien il n'y aurait pas d' espaces s'il
n'y aurait pas de décalage entre la
cause et son effet
l'idée c'est qu'un effet ne peut pas
prêt exister à sa cause l'effet est
toujours postérieure à sa cause
et dans un monde où le temps
n'existerait pas la cause et l'effet se
confondre et il ne ferait qu'un et dans
ce cas là il n'y aurait plus lieu de les
distinguer
dire qu'un effet ne peut pas prêt
exister à sa cause c'est dire que vous
ne pouvez pas avoir une tâche sur votre
chemise avant d'avoir fait couler la
sauce tomate dessus vous ne pouvez pas
être mouillé avant d'être sorti sous la
pluie sans votre parapluie la cause
vient toujours avant son effet est donc
le lien nécessité entre la cause et
l'effet s'il peut être conçu de manière
simultanée sur le plan logique il
nécessite toujours un écoulement du
temps dans la pratique
d'ailleurs cette idée de la temporalité
comme trame de fond de la causalité
on la retrouve également chez hegel
eagle qui nous explique que l'histoire
est le lieu de déploiement de la raison
universelle et que donc sans le temps
sans cet étirement de la trame de nos
actions
la raison universelle ne pourrait pas se
déployer et donc aucun apprentissage
aucun progrès vers le vrai ne serait
possible pour nous la deuxième
application de la loi du déterminisme
sur laquelle je vais m'arrêter beaucoup
plus longuement
c'est que le monde est rationnel
c'est une idée extrêmement importante
pour comprendre la pensée de spinoza une
idée très importante et beaucoup plus
profonde qu'elle ne peut en avoir l'air
dire que le monde est rationnel ou que
le réel et rationnelle
c'est dire qu'il existe une logique
derrière tout événement est d'ailleurs
le mot même de logique et connotés par
cette idée de rationalité quand quelque
chose n'est pas logique
ça signifie qu'elle n'est pas rationnel
et si elle n'est pas rationnel
elle n'est pas compréhensible elle n'est
pas compréhensible par la raison
par exemple si vous lâchez votre stylo
votre stylo va tomber au sol
il ne va pas à flotter dans les airs il
ne va pas se mettre à écrire tout seul
et il va pas se mettre à vous chanter
une chanson parce que ça ce serait
absurde
absurde signifiant vide de sens
le monde est rationnel autrement dit
l'effet n'est pas indépendant de sa
cause l'effet est contenue dans la cause
la cause enveloppe son effet elle inclut
de manière logique et nécessaire
et dans notre monde terrestre dans notre
monde physique rien ne peut arriver
qu'ils ne soient pas rationnel
tout ce qui arrive est rationnel au sens
où tout ce qui arrive à une logique
illogique causal logique de causes et
d'effets une logique déterminer
tout ce qui arrive est logique tout ce
qui arrive obéit aux logos à la raison
et ce qui nous semble échapper aux lois
de la raison
c'est tout simplement ce dont nous
n'avons pas réussi à identifier les
causes et c'est très différent de ne pas
être parvenu à identifier les causes et
d'affirmer que ses causes n'existe pas
c'est très différent de dire qu'on ne
comprend pas et de dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'explications possibles parce que quand
on dit qu'il n'ya pas d'explications
possibles on présuppose qu'il pourrait y
avoir des choses qui arrivent de manière
non rationnel
autrement dit on présuppose qu'il
pourrait y avoir des effets sans cause
mais ça c'est impossible
le réel est rationnel parce que tout ce
qui arrive est toujours le résultat d'un
enchaînement de causes et d'effets et
c'est parce que nous possédons la raison
c'est parce que nous possédons
l'intelligence qui nous est possible de
prévoir qu'il nous est possible
d'anticiper les effets à partir de leur
cause
quand vous sortez sous la pluie ce qui
fait que vous allez prendre votre
parapluie c'est l'anticipation de la
conséquence dont vous connaissez la
cause c'est l'anticipation du fait que
vous serez mouillé si vous ne prenez pas
votre parapluie
si peine et d'en anticiper il ya bien le
préfixe hanter le préfixe tu
l'antériorité anticiper c'est voir à
l'avance les conséquences de ce dont on
connaît les causes
c'est ça l'intelligence
la faculté de comprendre l'enchaînement
des causes et des effets pour pouvoir
les anticiper pour pouvoir les prêts
voire
parce que si on connaît les causes on
peut en déduire les effets
c'est une spécialité de l'être humain de
s'étonner des effets de ce dont il
connaissait les causes
on va faire quelque chose et on va
s'étonner des conséquences de notre
action
on va faire mine de ne pas comprendre
comme si on n'avait pas pu anticiper
agir bêtement c'est agir sans avoir
anticipé les effets de notre action
c'est agir en oubliant que le réel et
rationnelle
et donc l'une des conséquences du
déterminisme c'est qu'il n'ya jamais
lieu de s'étonner de ce qui arrive
pour être plus précis l'étonnement c'est
une réaction humaine spontanée qui
demande à être dépassés par la
compréhension
parce que bien souvent notre étonnement
se traduit par le fait de dire que ce
qui arrive n'a pas de sens que ce qui
arrive n'est pas logique
que ce qui arrive n'est pas possible
de causalité apparente ne signifie pas
absence de causalité tout court
il arrive très souvent que les
événements soient conduits par une
chaîne de causalité inapparente
par une logique invisible et affirmé
qu'il n'y a pas de logique dans un
phénomène c'est s'exposer à
l'humiliation intellectuelle lorsque
cette logique sera comprise et mise en
lumière
ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne comprend pas
la logique que cette logique n'existe
pas
l'étonnement ne doit pas être pensé
comme la réaction à une chose impossible
l'étonnement doit être le préalable à la
compréhension
le préalable au dévoilement de la chaîne
de causalité
c'est ce que disait aristote quand il
définissait la philosophie comme la
fille de l'étonnement la fille de
l'étonnement autrement dit c'est parce
que l'on ne comprend pas les causes d'un
phénomène que va naître en nous le désir
de comprendre ses causes
en ce sens étonnement et d'abord le
symptôme de notre ignorance
et ce n'est pas parce qu'une chose nous
paraît étonnante qu'elle n'a pas de
cause c'est au contraire parce qu'elle
est étonnante qu'elle doit nous conduire
à identifier les causes qu'elle doit
nous conduire à nous interroger pour la
comprendre
il est très bien de s'étonner mais il
est problématique de faire de son
étonnement une preuve de l'irrationalité
des choses
affirmer qu'une chose et irrationnel
n'est pas la preuve de l'irrationalité
de la chose
affirmer qu'une chose et irrationnel
c'est la preuve de notre orgueil
toute personne affirme que les choses
sont irrationnels du simple fait de leur
étonnement elles diront je ne comprends
pas donc ça n'a pas de sens je ne
comprends pas donc ce n'est pas logique
je ne comprends pas donc ce n'est pas
possible
est ce qu'il faut entendre dans ses
affirmations c'est ce qui précède ces
affirmations
je ne comprends pas
car ce qui est à l'origine de notre
étonnement ce ne sont pas les choses
c'est notre incapacité à comprendre les
choses qui arrivent
c'est notre incapacité à les inscrire
dans une chaîne de causalité rationnelle
mais cette chaîne de causalité
rationnelle existe nécessairement
car si elle n'existait pas les choses ne
pourraient pas arriver
rien n'arrive sans cause
j'en arrive qu'ils ne soient pas
rationnel
et quand je dis que tout est rationnel
saint-cloud également bien entendu les
phénomènes et les comportements dits
irrationnel
qu'est ce qu'on appelle un comportement
irrationnel comportement irrationnel
c'est un comportement dont on ne saisit
pas la logique dont on ne saisit pas la
cohérence
quelqu'un qui a subi d'importants
traumatismes qui a subi des violences
qui a subi des abus à développer des
comportements qui pourront nous semblait
irrationnel
par exemple une extrême agressivité
envers des personnes qui lui auront
peut-être rien fait de mal
et si on ne connaît pas les causes de
cette agressivité on va immédiatement
l'a qualifié d' irrationnelles
on va immédiatement affirmé que ça n'a
pas de sens mais cette agressivité peut
être tout simplement la réponse à la
peur de subir à nouveau une violence
dont on a été victime
une manière d'attaquer avant d'être
attaqué
contraire une tendance extrême à la
soumission sera peut-être la réponse à
la peur de revivre l'expérience de la
soumission
se soumettre avant d'avoir à se
soumettre
on juge irrationnelle chez les autres
les comportements qu'on n'adopterait pas
nous mêmes
et c'est parce que nous les adopterions
pas nous mêmes que nous les jugeons
irrationnelle parce que nous ne décelons
pas la chaîne de causalité qui en est à
l'origine
préférons jugé que comprendre et nous
mettons volontiers l'étiquette et
rationnelle sur ce qui ne coïncide pas
avec notre perception de la rationalité
mais la rationalité ne se réduit pas à
notre perception de la rationalité tout
phénomène est issu d'une combinaison de
causes et de facteurs que nous ignorons
pour la plupart
et nous appelons notre ignorance
irrationalité
et alors attention dire que tout ce qui
arrive à des causes dire que tout ce qui
arrive est compréhensible
ça ne veut pas dire que tout ce qui
arrive est légitime ou justifiable la
compréhension et la justification sont
deux choses distinctes comprendre c'est
se placer sur le terrain des causes se
placer sur le terrain
descriptif et analytique qui permet de
restituer la logique d'un phénomène
alors que justifier ce n'est pas se
passer sur le terrain des causes c'est
se placer sur le terrain des valeurs
c'est se placer sur le terrain normatif
du bien et du mal
mais on peut parfaitement comprendre les
causes d'un comportement sans pour
autant il souscrire moralement
sans pour autant considéré comme
légitime
on peut classer les valeurs au dessus
des causes
si quelqu'un vient vous voler votre
portefeuille il ya de fortes chances que
cette personne elle est de très bonnes
raisons de vous voler votre portefeuille
dans tous les cas il y à bien une chaîne
de causalité qui permet de comprendre la
logique qui a fait que la personne en
est arrivé à vouloir voler votre
portefeuille
et sauf que vous en tant que
propriétaire du portefeuille n'est pas
forcément intéressés pour connaître les
causes vous tous que vous allez vous
dire c'est que vous refusez qu on vous
vole votre portefeuille
et vous avez beau savoir qu'il existe
une chaîne de causalité qui a conduit
sept personnes à vouloir vous volez ça
ne modifiera en rien votre jugement
moral sur cette action
vous aurez placé la valeur avant la
cause
mais l'erreur ce serait de nier le fait
qu'il y ait des causes pour pouvoir
expliquer votre refus moral
chose n'est pas inacceptable parce
qu'elle n'a pas de cause une chose est
inacceptable quand vous placez les
valeurs au dessus des causes
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à la
citation de spinoza qui disait ne pas
rallier ne pas déplorer ne pas me dire
mais comprendre
spinoza remet la plupart de nos maux
viennent du fait que nous ne voulons pas
comprendre
nous ne voulons pas comprendre parce que
comprendre suppose un effort de la
raison comprendre suppose un travail un
travail actif
or il est plus facile d'être dans la
passivité intellectuelle il est plus
facile de rejeter un phénomène dans les
ténèbres de l'irrationalité que de
produire un effort de compréhension et
d'identification de la chaîne de
causalité
sauf que pour spinoza on n'échappe pas à
la souffrance par l'ignorance on
n'échappe à la souffrance en rejetant la
loi de la causalité en rejetant le fait
que tout ce qui arrive arrive en vertu
d'un enchaînement nécessaire de causes
et d'effets
on n'échappe à la souffrance en
comprenant pourquoi ce qui arrive arrive
le domino qui tombe
l'abonné qui écoute cet audio le
traumatiser qui fait preuve
d'agressivité tout à une explication et
le déterminisme qui régit le
comportement des corps physique n'est
pas moins applicable aux individus dotés
d'une conscience c'est-à-dire n'est pas
moins applicable aux phénomènes
psychiques
parce que de la même façon qu'il existe
pour spinoza des lois physiques les lois
qui régissent les interactions des corps
matériel
il existe des lois psychique des lois
qui régissent nos passions et nos
émotions des lois qui régissent ce que
spinoza appelle les affectent
dans les tic spinoza explique en quoi
tout est déterminé par la loi de la
causalité et en quoi le concept de libre
arbitre telle qu'on l'emploie dans la
vie de tous les jours
traduit en réalité notre ignorance des
causes qui nous détermine
nous nous croyons libre parce que nous
ignorons la plupart du temps pourquoi
nous faisons ce que nous faisons nous
pensons ce que nous pensons
espinosa utilisent cet exemple celui
d'une pierre qu'on ferait rouler sur le
sol en disant que s'ils ont doté cette
pierre d'une conscience elle se croirait
parfaitement libre de choisir sa
trajectoire
nous sommes des pierres qui roulent sur
le sol et parce que nous ignorons
pourquoi nous roulons dans telle ou
telle direction
nous supposons que c'est parce que nous
le décidons
cette comparaison a tendance à nous
choquer parce que nous estimons
spontanément qu'on ne peut pas mettre
sur le même plan des corps inertes et
des individus conscients
en réalité pour spinoza la seule
différence qui existe entre le
déterminisme qui s'applique aux corps
physique et celui qui s'applique aux
individus conscients c'est tout
simplement le degré de complexité des
causes qui déterminent le comportement
des individus conscients pour vous le
faire comprendre je vais recourir mais
aussi à un exemple simple prenons
l'exemple d'un joueur de billard
américain professionnel
ce joueur de billard sera capable de
prendre en compte un certain nombre de
paramètres physiques et géométriques
pour empocher une boule à l'issue d'une
trajectoire relativement complexe donc
le joueur de billard c'est celui qui
anticipent les faits ultime la boule
empoché d'une série de causes et
d'effets la force du tihan sa
trajectoire
les collisions avec d'autres boules etc
est ce qui rend la performance du joueur
impressionnante c'est qu'elle nécessite
de synthétiser un grand nombre
d'informations en plus de les mettre à
exécution
mais ce qui rend possible la performance
du joueur du billard c'est qu'il
applique son art à des corps physique
inerte
autrement dit à des objets qui vont se
comporter de manière mécanique la boule
de billard qui reçoit le tir elle n'a
pas le choix de sa trajectoire elle
obéit purement et simplement aux lois de
newton
donc si le joueur de billard rate son
exécution ce sera parce que les lois de
la causalité auront été abolie ce sera
parce qu'il a foiré son coup
maintenant quelle est la différence avec
nous autres êtres humains est-ce que
nous aussi nous sommes des boules de
billard en collision
hier selon spinoza oui le modèle de
causalité qui s'applique aux boules de
billard il s'applique aussi aux
comportements des hommes
mais la différence c'est qu'il est
beaucoup plus difficile de prédire le
comportement d'un être humain que de
prédire le comportement de la boule de
billard
pourquoi parce que l'être humain est
plus complexe
et complexes ne veut pas dire qu'ils
échappent à la loi de la causalité
eq signifie qu'il est mû par un nombre
de paramètres beaucoup plus important et
c'est parce que le nombre de paramètres
qui nous régissent forme d'un tissu de
causes et d'effets complexe qu'il est
beaucoup plus difficile de prédire le
comportement humain que de prédire le
comportement d'un corps physique
si vous préférez nous sommes une boule
de billard sur un tapis à 1000 bande
mais l'infinie complexité de la
causalité humaine n'abolit pas le
mécanisme
elle n'abolit pas le déterminisme
elle empêche simplement d'en faire une
science exacte
pourquoi parce que l'esprit humain n'est
pas capable d'englober il n'est pas
capable de concevoir l'intégralité des
causes et des effets qui régissent nos
pensées et nos actions
pour arriver à prédire notre
comportement il faudrait que joueur de
billard soit aux missions et c'est
précisément la fonction des algorithmes
informatiques d'intégrer un maximum de
micro informations pour pouvoir
anticiper notre prochaine action notre
prochaine penser
donc on tenait bien ça ce qui rend la
prédiction du comportement humain
particulièrement difficile ce n'est pas
le fait que les actions humaines échappe
aux lois du déterminisme c'est le degré
de complexité des causes qui nous
détermine
mais si vous avez bien suivi ce
raisonnement vous aurez compris que
entre le comportement des corps physique
et le comportement des corps conscient
il n'ya pas une différence de nature
mais différence de degré
autrement dit nous sommes tout autant
soumis aux lois mécaniste du
déterminisme que ne l'est la boule de
billard
et l'illusion la liberté c'est notre
capacité à intégrer la totalité des
informations qui nous détermine
pour ceux qui n'osent arbres la matière
et l'esprit le corps et la pensée ne
sont pas des choses de nature différente
le corps et l'esprit sont la même chose
mais perçue sous des attributs
différents perçue sous des perspectives
différentes espinosa pense que si on
comprend les lois qui régissent nos
affects
si on comprend les lois du déterminisme
du corps et de l'esprit bien ce moment
là il sera possible d'accéder à une
forme de liberté
car la liberté chez spinoza n'est pas le
détachement vis-à-vis du déterminisme
puisque ça ça n'est pas possible
la liberté chez spinoza c'est
l'augmentation de notre puissance d'agir
et c'est ce que nous allons voir
maintenant
spinoza considère que les êtres humains
sont soumis à deux types d'affect les
affects de joie et les affects de
tristesse les affects de joie sont ceux
qui augmentent notre puissance d'agir et
al'inverse les affects de tristesse sont
ceux qui diminue notre puissance d'agir
et augmenter sa puissance d'agir c'est
la définition que donne spinoza la
liberté
or ce qui n'osa nous explique que
comprendre les causes d'un phénomène
s'accompagne d'un affect de joie
autrement dit comprendre nous rend
joyeux
et si comprendre nous rend joyeux alors
comprendre augmente notre puissance
d'agir
alors vous allez me dire c'est étrange
qu'est ce qui permet à spinoza
d'affirmer que comprendre nos rangs
joyeux
est ce qu'au contraire la compréhension
des choses n'auraient pas plutôt
tendance à nous rendre triste
anoh rendre pessimiste
à nous faire perdre tout espoir
c'est l'idée qu'on retrouve chez
schopenhauer l'idée que c'est
précisément notre conscience qui est à
l'origine de notre souffrance
et que vivre sans avoir la conscience de
ce qui est est encore le meilleur moyen
de ne pas sombrer dans le désespoir
c'est vrai
dans une vision du monde déterministe
pas dans une vision du monde dans
laquelle tout ce qui arrive doit arriver
en vertu de la loi de nécessité parce
que partant du principe que tout ce qui
arrive à une raison d'arrivée est par
définition une raison est toujours une
bonne raison sinon quoi elle ne serait
pas une raison partant de ce principe là
deux options sont possibles
comprendre on ne pas comprendre parce
que de toute façon
comprennent ou qu'on ne comprennent pas
les choses qui doivent arriver
continueront à arriver
et les choses qui ne doivent pas arriver
continueront pas arrivé donc c'est
inextricable
il n'y a aucun moyen d'échapper à cette
loi du déterminisme
il n'y a aucun moyen de faire que ce qui
doit arriver n'arrive pas et donc se
priver de la compréhension des causes de
ce qui arrive c'est se priver de la joie
qui accompagne tout acte de
compréhension
la compréhension est un acte par lequel
nous augmentons notre puissance d'agir
et cette augmentation notre puissance
d'agir se confond avec la joie
comprendre les causes de ce qui arrive
c'est devenir actif par sa raison
et ce faisant on ne devient pas esclave
du déterminisme on devient un acteur du
déterminisme
on devient acteur de la nécessité qui
régit les phénomènes du monde
la liberté chez spinoza n'est pas la
sortie du déterminisme c'est la
compréhension du déterminisme qui
produit en nous une augmentation de
notre puissance d'agir
la liberté chez spinoza c'est la
participation active à la nécessité
ici que le spinozisme se fait stoll si
selon alors ici seulement parce que
spinoza est assez critique envers le
stoïcisme auquel il reproche de croire
dans l'illusion de la volonté auquel il
reproche de croire que la volonté pour s
autodéterminer et que nous serions ainsi
capable d'agir par libre décret pour
spinoza nous n'agissons jamais par libre
décret nous agissons en tant que nous
sommes affectés par des causes qui
augmente ou qui diminue notre puissance
d'agir et c'est la compréhension des
causes de ce qui nous affecte qui
devient un moyen de se libérer de ce qui
va diminuer notre puissance d'agir
autrement dit c'est l'affect de joie
produit par la compréhension des causes
qui va permettre de diminuer l'affect de
tristesse produit par l'ignorance des
causes et ce qui réduit notre liberté
chez spinoza n'est pas le fait que tout
soit déterminé ce qui réduit notre
liberté chez spinoza c'est le fait que
nous soyons affecté par des choses dont
nous ne connaissons pas les causes et
n'en connaissant pas les causes nous les
subissons nous en sommes esclaves
c'est ça la servitude on parle spinoza
la servitude de l'ignorance des causes
qui nous détermine ce qui réduit notre
liberté n'est donc pas le déterminisme
ce qui réduit notre liberté ce sont les
affects de tristesse qui sont le produit
de l'ignorance les affects de tristesse
sont la trace de notre refus de l'ordre
rationnelle au contraire comprendre
c'est accepté l'ordre rationnelle c'est
consentir à l'ordre rationnelle et s'y
inscrire
car en comprenant l'ordre rationnelle
j'accède à la joie
j'accède à ce que spinoza appelle la
béatitude chez spinoza
contrairement aux stoïcien le but n'est
pas de supprimer l'affect cas pour
spinoza on ne supprime jamais l'affect
le but est de combattre les affects de
tristesse par les affects de joie le
c'est de combattre les affects qui
diminue notre puissance d'agir par des
affects qui augmente notre puissance
d'agir car lorsqu'on est affecté par la
joie on devient actif face à la
nécessité actifs par notre raison on
entre dans la liberté humaine
à présent vous lire un passage de
l'éthique de spinoza
il s'agit d'un extrait de sa préface à
la cinquième partie une cinquième partie
intitulée de la puissance de
l'entendement ou de la liberté de
l'homme je cite je passe enfin à cette
autre partie de l'éthique où il s'agit
de la manière de parvenir à la liberté
ou de la voix y conduisant j traiterait
donc de la puissance de la raison
montrant ce que peu la raison elle-même
contre les affections et ensuite ce
qu'est la liberté de l'âme ou béatitude
par où nous verrons combien le sage
l'emportant pouvoir sur l'ignorance
quant à la manière de porte l
entendement à sa perfection et à la voix
et conduisant ce sont choses qui
n'appartiennent pas au présent ouvrage
non plus que l'art de traiter le corps
de façon qu'ils puissent remplir
convenablement sa fonction cette
dernière question est du ressort de la
médecine l'autre de la logique ici comme
je les dis je traiterai donc de la seule
puissance de l'âme c'est à dire de la
raison est avant tout je montrerai
combien d'empyr et qu'elle sorte dans
pire elle assure les infections pour les
réduire et les gouvernés
l'erreur qu'on trouve souvent dans les
interprétations de la pensée de spinoza
c'est la confusion entre le déterminisme
et le fatalisme
or le fatalisme se traduit souvent par
l'idée de passivité
une question qui résume bien l'esprit
fataliste c'est à quoi bon
à quoi bon puisque quoi que je fasse les
jeux sont déjà faits
le fatalisme c'est de dire je ne décide
de rien car tout est décidé d' avance
l'erreur c'est de confondre le
déterminisme et le prêt déterminisme
le prédéterminisme c'est l'idée que mes
actions n'ont aucune influence sur le
cours des choses
c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans la notion
de destin
l'idée que nous sommes fondamentalement
un puissant et c'est cette impuissance
qui rendrait nulle et non avenue
notre désir de vouloir accéder à la
liberté
et si je dis ça c'est pour vous montrer
que la relation qui établit spinoza
entre liberté et puissance est une
relation que nous concevons parfaitement
lorsque nous la renversons lorsque nous
définissons la servitude comme
impuissance c'est précisément parce que
la servitude est impuissant ce que la
liberté et ^ ^ n'ont pas de sortir du
déterminisme puissance ment pas d'abolir
les lois du déterminisme mais puissance
d'y prendre part
t'y prendre part activement d'y prendre
part
dans la joie le déterminisme ne
contredit pas la liberté humaine
le déterminisme enveloppe la liberté
humaine car la liberté n'est rien
d'autre que le fait d'être actif face
aux lois du déterminisme est certes le
fait d'être passif ou actif face au
déterminisme ne relève pas d'une libre
volonté ça relève d'une nécessité
mais ce n'est pas parce que mon
comportement relève de la nécessité que
je suis obligé de m'inscrire dans la
passivité face à cette nécessité
autrement dit être actif et être passifs
sont deux modalités du déterminisme mais
dans l'activité
j'exprime ma puissance d'agir
et ce faisant je suis libre
berthe et ce n'est pas l'abolition de la
nécessité la liberté c'est la
réalisation active de la nécessité
liberté ce n'est pas je décide la
liberté c je comprends
et parce que je comprends j'accède à la
joie
jean qui correspond à l'augmentation de
ma puissance d'agir
la joie qui exprime l'adéquation de ma
raison à la nécessité
la liberté chez spinoza c'est la
communion de l'esprit et de la nécessité
parce que nous avons ce pouvoir non
seulement de comprendre les causes qui
nous déterminent mais aussi d'être
affectés par la joie lorsque nous
comprenons que nous pouvons accéder à la
liberté
encore une fois la liberté ce n'est pas
sortir du déterminisme sortir de la
nécessité la liberté c'est prendre part
activement à la nécessité
si en lisant spinoza ou en écoutant cet
audio le désir augmentant vous de
comprendre les causes qui vous détermine
ce faisant augmente votre puissance
d'agir et votre joie ça ne voudra pas
dire que spinoza or a aboli les lois du
déterminisme et ça voudra dire que les
lois du déterminisme vous auront conduit
à augmenter votre puissance d'agir
et c'est ça l'important
on n'est pas que l'augmentation de la
puissance d'agir soit conçu comme étant
déterminée
important est que cette puissance d'agir
s'exprime en étant par ailleurs comprise
comme étant déterminée
s'il a conscience du déterminisme vous
fait penser que quoi vous fassiez salle
sert à rien parce que tout est déterminé
alors ça veut dire que vous n'avez pas
compris ce qu'est le déterminisme
repris dans les lois du déterminisme ça
ne veut pas dire être passif
ça ne veut pas dire subir le
déterminisme
la conscience du déterminisme ne doit
pas mener à la passivité
ce serait un total contresens car même
si votre compréhension des causes est
elle même déterminée
il n'empêche que cette compréhension va
entraîner une augmentation de votre
puissance d'agir
il ne dépend pas de notre volonté de
comprendre mais parce que comprendre
augmente notre puissance d'agir
comprendre augmente notre liberté
et dégainer la carte du déterminisme
pour dire que nous n'avons pas
d'influencé sur le cours des choses
c'est confondre le déterminisme et le
fatalisme c'est ne pas comprendre la
logique de l'articulation entre
compréhension de la nécessité et
augmentation de la puissance d'agir
la compréhension est un acte et cet acte
engendre de la joie qui engendre un
rapport actif à l'existence
parce qu'une idée est une substance
agissante parce que la prise de
conscience entraîne une modification de
nos affects la connaissance nous rend
actif la connaissance nous rend libres
on peut être l'oeuvre de spinoza est
elle d'abord une oeuvre destinée à nous
faire éprouver cette joie
lire spinoza c'est se donner l'occasion
d'être affectés par la joie
c'est se donner l'occasion d'augmenter
notre puissance d'agir
phl et aux autres le désir de comprendre
les causes affecter les autres de la
volonté d'aller vers la joie
ce n'est pas contredire le déterminisme
mais c'est produire un effet un effet
sur les autres
un effet sur le monde
a pas de contradiction entre le fait
d'être déterminée et le fait d'être
libre c'est parce que l'on peut être
déterminé à être libre et ainsi résoudre
la contradiction si être libre c'est se
faire les porte voix du déterminisme
c'est justement pour ne pas se faire les
porte voix de la fatalité être libre
faire les porte voix de la compréhension
des causes
une compréhension qui conduit à
l'augmentation notre puissance qui
conduit à la joie
qui conduit à la béatitude
la seule vraie liberté je vous remercie
[Musique]